c'est le cac ascenseur
oh
[Musique]
cinquième au cinquième mois si vous êtes
le mec de le mec de star porno star non
je pense à vide et au ghana
c'est une médecine de ville c'est vrai
ça vous manque pas un métier coup le
danton et confrère montpetit fait
réellement rien ne manque
moi je sais que j'ai 26 ans mais c'était
mieux vous et sébastien folin ouais non
voilà quelques mois ça fait plaisir de
vous rencontrer en tout cas vraiment
[Musique]
olalala ono [ __ ] c'est pas beau ça me
suis le pire des claustro mon ami
j'appelle les pompiers direct ne veulent
pas donc jusque là aujourd'hui c'est le
pire que l'amour c'est pire que la
mauvaise journée
j'ai une gastro le réseau réseau
disponible en boutique en plus là ça me
stresse chanthu grave que ça me stresse
si je vous lâche desquels je suis désolé
tiens témoins réseau indisponible
vous avez le terme là c'est parti la
première année déjà parti je suis désolé
et d'appuyer comme un coup de quoi bah
ouais non mais s'il faut bien que ça
franchement décalé pas ce que je vais
vous lâcher une seule pièce mon ami oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] fait du bien ça
glisse beaucoup
passionnément 350 beaucoup les looks des
jambes la [ __ ] comment je suis pas
monsieur aulas c'est quoi ton nouveau
toit [ __ ] bernard pita bernhard sch
pas bien [ __ ] attention je m'en fous
dans le coin c'est pas là il y avait des
barrières l'une à côté de l'autre je me
tiens mis au monde comment j'ai mal au
bout
35 ans l'âge où je vais te tuer
[Applaudissements]
les
on tue la femme qui parle mais j'adore
je vais te tuer le très calmes bernard
montiel du rallye il va te tuer mais
mais il est trop de l'anac a failli
vraiment s'énerver
c'est mokhtar l'ascenseur avec tard
regardez il est très très drôle et
mokhtar en fait ça s'est pas passé comme
on aurait voulu à la fin mais c'est très
drôle quand même
mokhtar le cac ascenseur sais pas
m
oh
on
[Musique]
il m'arrive est une galère une fois je
me suis trouvé que j'ai passé ma soirée
dans le trouve que la personne qui vous
savez confiance sans même chercher ils
sont venus chez com sur lequel 18 allée
sont venus à 3 merci de patienter un
conseiller va prendre notre appel
sheibani j'aime passer par là
[Musique]
si on la porte avec des gros projets de
t'énerver vous moi là je pense que les
cellules sont servis de 39 ans c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon signe tous
commencent à laisser rentrer le premier
voila voila tu vois [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
oui
c'est un des plus beaux pigeons et les
insultes je la exceptionnel alors je
dirais merci courage à lui
[Musique]